one of the things that fascinated me was
thinking where when I was look at your
work realizing that there's some there's
some very interesting health
implications for this because you know
just as an example when you looked at
smoking you found that you know as
people in the crowd probably know so you
know there's been these a lot of the
hard-working people stop smoking and for
several decades at work we're going down
down down until we got to vote about one
in five but twenty percent of the people
are still smoking and that is just worse
than young people yeah yeah it's right
yeah and it's sort of stopped there and
there hasn't been as much success in
getting any lower and there was sort of
a mystery as to why is it that we can
get at that loan not lower and I'm bored
I looked at your research it seemed to
suggest an answer because the smokers
were clustered networks know that we're
not connected to non-smokers anymore so
if non smoking is a contagious behavior
they can't catch it from them because
they're not talking to is that is that
so that's one possible one way of
looking I mean I've been accused
variously of being a bit of a zealot I
guess I am a kind of another fella so
you know when you're the hammer
everything looks like a nail or so I
always have to resist the temptation to
see everything as a network phenomenon
yeah and of course there can be many
explanations for the same thing yeah
probably a network story but the way I
would describe this is so imagine you
have a wedding banquet and there are 10
tables of 10 people and uh and I tell
you that every minute a bells going to
ring and ten percent of the people are
going to leave right there in the
extremes at least two ways this can
happen at the bell rings and one person
from each table goes and then another
bell rings and then one person from each
table goes and so so the size of the
number of people at any given table
declined smoothly from 10 29 28 27 on
down and the total number of people in
the room declined smoothly but an
alternative way that the people could
leave the room is when the bell rings
everyone at one table gets up and leaves
hmm so then until the very end all the
tables have the same number of people
they have 10 people so any table that
has anybody has 10 people at the table
so this is analogous to what can happen
in networks where clusters of
individuals change your behavior at the
same time
in one scenario you have kind of a
smooth kind of homogeneous ly
distributed through the population
decline in a kind of behavior right
where everyone stochastically has a kind
of probability of quitting smoking right
and in the other scenario you have whole
groups of smokers who are interconnected
quit simultaneously all get up from the
same table and leave so that by the end
you may have a couple of tables twenty
percent right where they just don't get
up and go they're all nobody's running a
boat together yeah and there's no one at
the table that's getting up and going to
sort of stimulate their reflection so
there is a sense in which that can be
happening else's